bref, plus tendu on commence à appeler le
numéro un
nous avons le numéro 2 3 4 5 6 heures aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans l'urgence
voyons tout maintenant comme ça
nous avons
prédit était derrière
Non
c'est l'histoire de la gs excelsior
ce qu'on appelle l'équipe la plus
perdant de l'italie une équipe qui ne
ne gagne jamais sur un terrain mais gagne
J'ai dit ne me demande pas de faire semblant
de l'exterieur
manger de la parole c'est aller faire le
jeu à perdre mais ça ne me dérange pas
le fait de perdre me pèse bien tu perds
le match parce que si j'encaisse 21 buts par
la montagne comme c'est arrivé l'année dernière est
à droite qu'il a fait 21 mixtes parce que
on aurait même pu en faire 30 mais si j'avais
Je prends 21 buts au moins 18 je pourrais
éviter parce qu'il n'y avait pas de désir parce que
nous n'avons pas couru parce que nous faisons les choses habituelles
fautes bêtes car oui oui je prends le
des choses comme ça alors on y est de vacances
l'exception ne signifie pas nécessairement
cependant nous sommes condamnés à perdre
toujours de toute façon parce que je ressens
fois donc aujourd'hui je n'ai pas tellement aujourd'hui un
baise-nous avec qui nous sommes, nous devons
essaie toujours de gagner quand même
ok parce que c'est parfois nous le ferions
tant aujourd'hui tant aujourd'hui que tant aujourd'hui
Qu'est-ce
voici l'endroit et le terrain où presque
Il y a 14 ans, il a commencé et a commencé le
histoire d'excel si les garçons qui ont
formé l'équipe avec nous
ils passaient les après-midi sur ce terrain et
les semelles étaient littéralement usées
des chaussures parce que c'étaient des garçons
certainement différents les uns des autres avec
intérêts différents mais ils étaient tous unis
d'une seule passion qui fut celle de
le football devait en sortir
campetto devait être une vraie équipe
membre de la fédération italienne des jeux
football et faire leur propre championnat
le désir était de s'en sortir
lancer et affronter les équipes
tu mérites
nous sommes une association qui travaille dans le
social
nous sommes nés avec les deux domaines qui nous ont
puis identifié dans les années qui sont
indiquer la zone de dépendances ok mais
nous nous en sommes également occupés dès le début
enfants ayant des problèmes familiaux
domaine de la femme dans lequel nous intervenons ensuite
J'explique ce qu'il y a de mieux pour soutenir les femmes et
hommes victimes de traite et d'exploitation
de la prostitution parfaitement et nous
Il y a 14 ans, nous avons opté pour celui-ci
association que nous voulions essayer
utiliser le sport comme un outil
éducatif et nous avons décidé de l'essayer
couler une équipe de football
nous avons dit si d'un côté il y a
sélection exclusion nous raisonnons
à la place sur l'inclusion bienvenue e
égalité
nous ne nous soucions pas si vous jouez
bon au football
Je suis intéressé à comprendre si vous avez un
au lieu de cela grand désir de mesurer l'anti
avec tes limites
toucan détenteurs du même statut
ça veut dire que tout le monde devant nous dit alla
équipe devant le ballon sont égales et
sens qu'ils auront le même droit de
jouer les mêmes minutes dans le cours
de l'année comme leurs compagnons et les
tournons essayons d'aller dans l'autre sens
comme toutes les équipes lors de leur premier match
il y avait une certaine émotion et nous aussi
nous y sommes arrivés un peu au dépourvu
nous savions déjà ce qui nous attendait
dans le bureau de l'arbitre pour remettre
les listes nous étions vraiment en difficulté
pour comprendre si tout était en ordre alors
échauffement sur le terrain avec moi
les joueurs qui ont bougé regardent si
il y avait des bouteilles d'eau s'il y avait des balles
pour le réseau
et nous voilà enfin prêts à commencer
nous sommes prêts à entrer sur le terrain et
l'arbitre nous dit que les gars ici manquent le
lignes
maintenant appelons le dit du champ
qu'avec le spargessero tracer les lignes
rapide et le plus tordu jamais vu
dans l'histoire
quand on a les quatre lignes sur les côtés
mais on s'aperçoit qu'il manque l'un des
milieu de terrain et nous demande ensuite de
nous devons tous lui tendre la main
la main comme ça et faire en créer un grand
boussole humaine dessinant le cercle
Giotto avait quelque chose là aussi
dire et c'était pour que nous ayons pour le
première fois dans l'histoire du football et
même les lignes du terrain de foot
central
alors d'abord se plaindre des serviettes
le mouvement marche le tout avec le
maillot de barbier en sueur mais on estime que
sont seulement ces champs jusqu'à comment
passé je n'avais pas pris et sinon
J'ai eu le ticket je ne sais pas comment
nous avons réussi à passer et maintenant non
laisse moi défocaliser que nous avons commencé
mauvais jour
les gars mais je dois toujours tout penser moi-même
Je ne pouvais pas le prendre de cosmétiques privés
carte mère déjà faite puis une alliance
due conti 3 rosa 4 mirko 5 alfano 6
favaretto 7 francesco 8 k 9 ivan 10
vous avez 11 membres plus 12 robbie 13 ans
14 max 15 autocollants cara 16 sur je ne veux pas
les gens manifestent aussi sur le terrain
nous savons clairement que vous avez raison
taisez-vous si vous commettez la faute habituelle
le discours civil s'excuse
à l'adversaire
ça ne veut pas dire que nous sommes venus
ici pour complexe mais faisons-le
respecte personne ne sèche
les gars vous essayez de prendre le miroir
de la porte nous n'essayons pas de les faire
fileté vous savez avec la balle autour de pas
nous sommes capables
si nous sommes capables de le mettre là, il vient 2
puis que le gardien bouge
semaine avant et met la main dessus
ok voyons une sucette sèche
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui sera un match
très dur
nous avons quand même quelques petites choses à nous
service
1 nous n'avons pas à gagner mais
nous allons tout donner pour
que nous tous quand nous sortons nous devrions
pouvoir se dire qu'on a donné le meilleur de soi
souvenons-nous aussi du fair-play qui
celui de nous est notre billet
de la visite
bravo ressemble à un sommet de la mode 8 chez les hommes
quand la balle arrive, nous devons
manger fille coups de pied de coin réguliers
marquer avant que le ballon ne parte
quand le ballon quitte les gars de l'extérieur
sur le banc mais hoopla ensuite
Je vois ça dans la bouche après
tu peux faire ce que tu veux mais avant
match vous ne fumez pas à la fois sur le terrain si
nous suivons l'armée brancaleone comme si
nous avons dû décider [ __ ] je ne vois pas le feu
aux yeux déterminés vilains garçons
mauvais pas que crava compétitif
post allons à l'intérieur décidé qu'ils l'ont fait
voir qui nous sommes
nous faisons des erreurs de base stupides
le premier quart d'heure il sembla que le
la défense n'avait jamais joué ensemble
ils ont quelque chose de plus ils savent qu'ils gagnent
ou le pardon ils savent que le sourire est toujours là
ce qui manque tant de gens et peu
ils peuvent aussi enseigner accepter les
vaincre avec le sourire n'est pas facile pour eux
heureux de gagner contre excelsior devait
être une chose facile à la place en un
un jeu d'équipe sur la demi-heure oui
se rend compte que nous sommes toujours 0-0
la tension monte mais voilà que dans un
balle de la main instantanée dans la surface de réparation
nous sommes désespérés ils vont tous heureux
sur place coup de pied le jour est
le champ plein de trous est vraiment pénible
de flaques notre gardien de but devine
le coin droit du football, cependant, est là
la balle est trop rapide, elle semble entrer dans
porte pas la flaque d'eau ralentie ça
à tel point que cela permet à notre gardien de
touchez-le du bout des doigts et le
le ballon va en corner, réjouissez-vous
toute l'équipe qu'il avait sur al
portier
très content de ce truc en attendant
des adversaires plus intelligents que nous frappent
le corner 1 avec un coup sûr
alors que le gardien est toujours hors but
tir et but
personne de notre peuple ne le prend
exactement sur la jambe c'est reparti
sur 0 à 0 qu'est-ce que tu fais ici pitbull
course tu es l'attaquant désolé j'étais
est venu complimenté pourquoi
vraiment un défilé comme celui-ci que je n'ai jamais eu
voir
toujours sur 0 à 0 pour dire la vérité
mais ce match s'est terminé 4 1 pour eux
Salut les gars
j'ai approché les classes d'utilisation orc
un tel cas un dimanche au bar samhain
Je prenais un café et parlais à Pedro
stefano coach je ne connaissais même pas
s'entraîner dans l'équipe de football e
on lui a demandé ce que tu faisais
nous avons perdu l'autre dans le dernier match
esprit à 0 20 à 0 mais quelle équipe lenin o
et je riais aussi je n'ai pas payé ce n'est pas
possible dit que je jouais au football
pour l'âme 20 buts pris un match
maintenant j'ai commencé à m'expliquer
quel était l'excès que j'ai approché
j'ai aussi d'abord opté pour
jouer une fois joué dans le but et j'ai
a commencé à s'entraîner
alors pour d'autres raisons je ne pouvais pas
jouer
le groupe j'aimais les garçons je
Ils ont aussi aimé le projet
est resté en ligne maintenant c'est le cinquième
année que je collabore avec la démesure alors
le résultat patience ou pas
on cherche le résultat n'est pas un
la croissance est un chemin de vie
appelle pour faire de ces gars quelqu'un
avec quelques problèmes et nous lui donnons le
chance pour ces enfants de
affronter d'autres possibilités que je
les équipes nées n'avaient pas de pourquoi
malheureusement le monde va bien maintenant
même pas bon du beau du laid nous
on s'en fout de ça, tu viens avec nous
rejoignez le groupe si vous vous sentez à l'aise
car nous sommes une grande famille
reste faire quoi alors faire
nous vous apprenons à respecter
de l'adversaire et de l'arbitre des choses qui
moi dans ma jeunesse quand je jouais au che
Je jouais pour gagner certainement pas nous c'était un
po peut-être même un graveleux même si c'était
un peu trop exagéré et je suis
soudainement trouvé de l'autre côté à la place
et prêcher le calme respecte les choses qui
peut-être que je n'étais pas le premier à penser à lui
le temps que j'ai appris ça et ainsi pour moi
cette chose et changer les gens maintenant
c'est moi qui dois dire les gars finis
respect sur le terrain vous pouvez le
équité et loyauté envers nos
adversaire particulièrement perdu à vie
Ouah
vous êtes la Juventus de six courses laide
interviewé 6
Je voulais partager le double mais avec toi
il parait que c'est la tête de boitier et de même
paroisse
ce n'est pas facile aussi parce qu'ayant joué
même un certain niveau quand j'étais
jeune lisse cette mentalité tu dois
gagner tu dois bien faire et quand je le suis
la proposition a été faite de coacher et
l'excelsior je venais d'une année où j'étais
marre et fatigué et j'en ai dit assez
Je voulais rester un an pour pouvoir partir
autour de ce vélo
si moi mon partenaire et aller chez mes parents
parents est plutôt sous l'insistance de
maximum j'ai cédé car connaissant le
Je projette la situation des garçons
ce serait dommage de ne plus les revoir
jouer ou lire les partitions sur
journal a ensuite déchiré la promesse
que j'aurais fait l'aller-retour et après deux
semaines je lui ai dit vava massimo
allez-y doucement si vous avez besoin de trouver un
autre coach parce que j'arrête tout
l'année jusqu'à la fin je reste et c'est
été ma sixième saison rien de plus
a accouché de bien appliqué je vous dis
toutes les cagoules robbie Bordon de Carlo
adresses doublure dans le hamas pas si
marchetti mais grouille en ligne je ne vais pas
pise perdant rome
et puis je peux di roma les combos qui
suit
très beaux métiers à tisser historiques qui le font encore
étudier il s'avère
et c'est un truc qui t'appelle alors d'abord
j'ai entendu maximum découvert et couvert et
ils ont dit que tu devais te présenter
Samedi matin de 9h à 9h
piazza va à la collection walter la stuff de
jouer avec les trucs pour y jouer
doivent également garder leur équipe de
travailler quand on est content il y a beaucoup moins
à bientôt lieux david emmi quand est le
tournoi toute la matinée se joue déjà de
martin le matin ouais ok je ne voulais pas
attends attention c'était il y a au moins
sur beaucoup
comment ça s'appelle pendant la journée
monde de la santé mentale eux-mêmes
et il y a tellement d'associations de qui vous êtes
un chien de nombreuses associations que vous faites un
grosse soirée
une grande fête avec de la musique alors
ils vous nourrissent, c'est bien
interdire oui et puis aujourd'hui comment ça s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est
s'est bien passé ce qui est cuit et aujourd'hui a
cuit vaut les crevettes et le deuxième plat
poisson pescara et 96 bacalà alla vicentina
et fan de polenta c'est beau suit au moins
donc les dents des heureux grands-parents sont parfaites
puis il devait se rendre à la grotte
dit un cafettino nous écouter est une annonce
antonio vas-y si le
sauter fait qu'il m'a appelé en premier
oui c'était un peu bas un peu triste jeu
parce qu'il m'a dit que c'était quelques jours
que je ne te vois pas ça ne vaut pas de lui
faire un saut tranquille écouté le
ce qui a fait de Téhéran
avez-vous vu dans le nouveau depuis ce jour oui
tout ça par exemple
qui est ce drôle
Merci
tout ce que le seigneur fait ces quelques
robbie est notre gardien de but un gardien de but
mythique qui ne ferait de mal à personne
Moscou est ce qui a toujours été le
quatrième gardien de chaque équipe
pourtant dans un jeu où tout
ça a semblé calme à un moment donné
robbie sort des poteaux va vers le terrain
il l'a avec l'arbitre monte à
près de la moitié du terrain
il crie l'insulte on ne comprend pas non plus
parce que notre coach qui fait oui
se lève du banc et part à leur recherche
calmez-le doucement l'arbitre le ramène
dit-il ou vous l'arrêtez et le jetez dehors
don red non pour le reste de la
correspondre
permet à notre entraîneur de se tenir debout
au lieu d'être sur le banc derrière le
porte lui dire robbie comme maman statue
tout va bien et chez moi tout va bien depuis les ronces
ne t'inquiète pas, parlons d'autre chose
tu feras dimanche c'était comme ça
nous avons réussi à arriver l'esprit tranquille
jusqu'à la fin du jeu et la
adversaires adversaires de l'époque
ils n'ont plus jamais tiré au but
cela permet également d'accéder à
devenir quelque chose d'extraordinaire
dates martel cent et voir si le
d'autres vous êtes des romans que vous êtes peut-être
un peu plus fort et moralement tu sais
ce qu'il doit essayer de motiver
aussi l'équipe 13 quand tu bannières
comme un enfant avec une certaine discipline avec
une certaine habitude de compétition
en compétition tu trouves ça tout à fait normal
une certaine agressivité qu'on ne peut pas ici
exprimer pourquoi pourquoi faire avec
a 70 80 pour cent des personnes qui ne
ils ont grandi avec cette discipline et
ils ne savent pas comprendre interpréter pourquoi
voici des gars qui ne le sont pas
a grandi avec cet état d'esprit et si
s'ils se sentent s'ils se sentent attaqués
ils pensent que vous attaquez le
personne d'autre part comprennent que
coûts et attaquer le jeu que nous voyons
dimanche comme tu l'as dit non je veux dire
cava je ne l'ai pas avec k je suis parce que
J'étais loin j'ai vu la vue du jeu
différence avec lui même si ce n'est pas le sien
poste est une aide que je voulais apporter à
il danger de voir un di fig de ton
avec lequel les choses sont dites, cependant, est
Je suis arrivé il y a deux semaines est à
portes de maison comme une hyène voir un
qui perd le ballon et y reste ensuite
alors j'ai envie de crier, tu comprends
puis ce discours presque
cependant chaque fois que nous pouvons
reprendre dans le cou celui d'une équipe
ce qui est bien parce qu'il y a la démocratie sont
Je dois dire alors si je veux problème oui
propager la polémique devant tout le monde
pouvons parler face à face nous sommes
toujours disponible est une chose
beau à mon avis, c'est qu'il va commencer à partir de
nous proposons à la fin de chaque partie
aller encore dans tous les quartiers
centre du terrain et loin d'encore un autre
bravo à l'équipe
la plus belle chose à mon avis
pourrait faire, c'est que nous allons à la sortie
on fait le couloir de 22 rangées de
joueurs nous les donnons à 5
bons compliments oui bonjour bonjour
félicitations tu as fait une bonne chose
de ce genre tu peux faire pour moi alors
Je ne connais pas les autres tu m'adaptes ça me trouve
difficile déjà de voyager la main je dis
au revoir bon garçon je me suis retrouvé
difficile de faire l'autre déjà dans le même
quoi pas parce que quand je serai pour moi o
comment se baisser la salle des maladies passives
fortifié tu dois t'incliner
embrassez-vous complètement dites juste bonjour au milieu
au champ
ce qui change je ne parle que lorsque nous gagnons
au
un
Oui Non
D'habitude il n'y en a qu'un ok
me demande si certains nous suivent en fait le
rôle de conduite tu ne l'as pas fait
le même schéma est la même entreprise
Rien
mène à Bolsena
on va faire la blague dit oui
les bâtards passés ont touché toute la gale
super sur un penalty, il a supposé que c'était bien
et resserré fait le premier match
situation doutes perplexité mort
tout le monde joue tout le monde vient tout le monde vient un
jour aussi fabio un garçon avec beaucoup
beaucoup de capacité mais jamais
foulé un terrain de football ne sait pas
même pas les règles du terrain de football e
puis dans le match plutôt agité
maintenant nos camarades disent fabio tu
vous n'avez qu'une tâche pour marquer le chiffre 11
tu fais tout ce que fait le numéro 11
st collé lui aller où il est vous n'avez pas
ne le laisse jamais partir un instant et c'est ce qu'il fait
Fabio ne le laisse jamais partir
fermez toujours bien jusqu'à ce qu'un
certain moment du match l'entraîneur
de l'équipe adverse remplace le
le numéro 11 le numéro 11 quitte le terrain et un
à un certain moment on se rend compte que fabio lo
il a suivi jusqu'au vestiaire
nous avons dû le rappeler pour le faire
retourner sur le terrain
c'est vrai t'as vu le regard de carrière avec le
veste de cuir
ça ressemble à une Marseillaise mais pourrie
rester dans une hotte pour voyager
nous sommes là armoiries sans bonnes nouvelles
nous gagnons 1 0 après la première mi-temps
à trois cols sarko italease arc i
habituel
tout le monde loin
à partir des données que nous avons progressivement à la fois
Non
neuvième
Oui Non
amener des amis le grill
Non
le défi
cours
Assez
Je pense que de Coubertin devrait te faire
un vieux monument aussi de châtaignier
des doutes mais canelli fait là où il connaît des problèmes
Je sais parce que tu soulignes tout le mien
ignorance graphique merci parce que oui
il dit non l'important c'est de participer
de coubertin tu ne penseras pas à son homme
alors je l'ai toujours eu sans savoir
qui sait qui devrait faire un moment
parce que je pense que vous êtes la seule entreprise
qui joue pour trevi tu veux perdre
rapidement à la nôtre nous essayons qui n'est pas
le but du projet que nous n'essayons pas
alors ça commence toujours à 0 0
enlève ma curiosité et au revoir
discipline aiguë sauf cataclysme
Dimanche devrait être le dixième
notre milan l'étoile d'argent qui
maintenant chanter dans la tasse ou quelque chose
cependant le but est qui nous sommes
allez-y et puis c'est tout
ta coupe des champions pourquoi pas toi
tu te vantes de la première place mais
au moins des gants une chose qui me fait
beaucoup celui-là et du reste parce que c'est
droit dans la rangée la finalité qui
va jusqu'à la réalisation de nouveaux réseaux
a tout d'abord merci car sur le
Journal du dimanche si tu écrivais 10h
1 et non 12 à 1 comme donner perdre là
Je tiens à vous dire
juste un artiste photographe qui donne
cette année a décidé de faire un essai
réaliser son propre rêve qui est de
être un artiste photographe à plein temps e
essayer de vivre de mon art
le photographe depuis l'âge de 15 ans et
donc pour moi d'essayer de vivre de ça
c'est vraiment la réalisation d'un rêve
comme peut-être aussi pour beaucoup de gars qui
ils jouent en celsio pouvoir jouer en
une véritable équipe de troisième ordre e
alors réalisez votre rêve
il fait beau c'est beau juste parce que là
ce sont beaucoup de personnes différentes
il y a des enfants qui parlent italien
différents les uns des autres en tant que personnage supplémentaire
nous avons tous les garçons les garçons
étrangers venus s'intégrer
en combat d'équipe
peut-être qu'en Italie il y en a un peu moins
culture de l'immigration parce qu'on
la chose la plus récente que nous, les Italiens, ayons jamais été
utilisé pour aller à l'étranger pendant un certain temps
années sont les autres qui viennent à nous
c'est la nouveauté
mais je pense que juste les exemples comme
ex chelsea ou ils peuvent changer pour le leur
petit à l'entreprise je pense que l'ancien
sens doit vraiment être gardé à l'esprit comment
un bel exemple d'intégration
social
comment les aliments italiens
J'ai entré la passe courte 20 pour moi il y a
mal
ils savent
ici à buggiano sicile spa rose vie par
meilleur endroit pour nous de le faire au bon endroit
lochis milano ou génois hoskins les fans
dans les paniers il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ils ont des caractères de sensibilité qui sont
très labile très particulier alors
ce n'est pas facile de vivre ensemble n'est pas toujours
facile à vivre ensemble
il y a eu des querelles il y a eu
conflits il y a eu des situations
difficile et donc nous tous chacun chacun
s'entraîner à chaque match que nous devons
apprendre à gérer nos limites pour
ne tombe pas dans la discussion dans le
querelle et donc c'est un laboratoire
social très important car le
les gens pensent que nous nous amusons
perdons nous nous amusons à rire un peu
comme si nous étions un peu bêtes un peu
léger mais en réalité il y a du boulot
important derrière pourquoi
pouvoir garder la sérénité et
la joie du groupe
tu dois apprendre beaucoup de choses
les gens qui nous sont proches que dites-vous
si vous souhaitez venir vous entraîner de temps en temps
épouses de bons vins avec lui là-bas
Je pense que garder la forme a maintenant
arrêté pas le smash que vous avez arrêté est un
famille
la seule équipe a joué hier
j'ai joué à naples un album dans l'album e
puis bausano puis excelsior
voici la fesse en dernier dans le sens
lekesiz similaire qu'avez-vous fait c'est
vérifié que vous avez signé et tout au long du
vie
il est recommandé de donner un pourboire à sa médaille d'église
même maman qui est bonne à tout prix
ce qui est beau car la coupe est rare
ma discipline à 10 000 toriques et
comme c'est beau tous les 4 belle mère
mirabelle rappelez-vous qu'il en est ainsi si les actionneurs
la deuxième fois mais d'appeler un
commun toi le jaguar notre programme
et non les deuxièmes meilleures lignes du
tout le tyrol du sud et téhéran il marque
cette pompe
fait de voler v8 avec un gang
et le monoxyde motivé tache le sexe
vrai tout col de jeu de crédit très connu
papa à 62 ans
mais s'il pleut avec daniele plus calme
daniele a fait faillite mais en dessous c'est quoi
pour moi la première nuit où tu es arrivé
dans le camp il ne me connaissait pas mais avec le monde
du viseur dit à peu près dans mes souvenirs
que nous étions, nous faisons des séances d'entraînement et
lapo a vu 33 bustes chiffres derrière le
porte sont deux versements victime il ou il
ils ressemblent à une veste pour moi avec tout le
les goujons tu sais
oui mais ils avaient déjà eu un gilet
avec des clous et avec une chaîne
quelque chose alors walter me rend max
essayer d'entrer à l'intérieur 12
soyons euro chanceux beaucoup
nous voyons beaucoup ont lentement lentement
il y avait aussi ceux d'avant le match
aimait déjà faire la fête avant d'arriver
le sort plutôt changé peut-être avec
quelques verres de trop pendant la
jeu alors cela vous arrive
réaliser que pendant que tout le monde joue on est
là qui dit que je m'ennuie maintenant toi
tu ne me passes plus la balle et ça devient
bronzer tranquillement dans
au milieu du terrain en effet il enlève le
maillot de football et toujours sous le
chemise de pyjama où mais sur 15 à 0
essayer des mouvements à quoi ça sert n'essayez pas
perfectionnez-vous l'utiliser comme une séance d'entraînement
vous vous rendez parfait et ensuite sur des choses que vous
ils viennent automatiquement comme on dit
fille un de mes amis a dit que vous devez
essayer essayer
quand il retourne chez son partenaire il part
cet autre
J'ai toujours joué dans les hauts niveaux c'est-à-dire
Je me soucie vraiment de ce sport
et puis ça pour moi c'est me mettre dedans
jeu et prouver qu'il n'y a pas besoin
de 11 personnes qui savent jouer au football
mais ils font la différence ils font la
différence les câlins des gens
câlins même de la part de personnes qui ne le font pas
ils jouent dans les gens qu'ils représentent
les bancs vous regardent les gens qui
ils ont des problèmes physiques qu'avec les dieux
les petits gestes vous en donnent plus d'un
but de gagner un jeu et pour nous et
pour moi c'est une victoire et ça m'a
beaucoup appris
dans la vie respecte le prochain de chacun
c'est facile d'aller sur le terrain avec 11
joueurs de football et gagner le match
mais il faut du courage il faut
Vraiment
la patience demande vraiment de la force
caractère pour former 11 encore plus que
onze parce que nous sommes une équipe
très grand où tant de têtes différentes
où ils ne savent pas jouer aller sur le terrain e
faire un résultat
un point dimanche pour nous c'est le jeu
le plus important de l'année
nous nous souvenons nous commémorons et laissez-moi
dis aussi célébrons les nôtres
camarade qui n'est rien de plus que daniele
Daniele était un gars qui nous a
laissé un grand vide est aussi un
grand enseignement parce que parce que c'était un
garçon très malade mais avec nous celui-ci
la maladie comme par magie réussi à
laissez-le hors du champ à chaque fois
à tel point que beaucoup d'entre nous, y compris moi-même, le font
ils ont vraiment réalisé la gravité
de sa maladie
seulement quand il était déjà mort pense
Je ne le dis que pour les nouveaux qu'il a
parti il ​​y a quatre ans alors que nous
nous jouions à un jeu
la nouvelle est tombée alors que nous
nous avons joué même si nous l'avons
décidé de ne pas le dire pendant le match
probablement l'énergie ou quelque chose était là
dans les airs parce que dans ce match là
nous avons trois cartons rouges 3 4
avertissements en bref, nous sommes vraiment
vraiment beaucoup de tension est sortie
aime à croire qu'il y a même
lui aussi sur le terrain avec nous c'est
plus l'homme nous entrons dans le domaine que nous faisons
nous donnons ce cadeau à tous
maximum alors rendez-vous avec la fête pour l'elle
et on s'amuse
son honneur
la tête
fabio a le droit de le lui donner quand il a
tourné
tous
coupes sur 4 à partir de
Non
tome
je trouve
Oui Non
Non
à fabio ci-dessous
les garçons de coqs
but
né
une personne m'a dit une phrase
au début de l'expérience Excel si
il est toujours resté ici et pour moi c'était
comme un phare sur lequel guider la route e
elle a dit personne même le plus
grand champion même plus le champion
payé au monde pourra faire une belle
match de ce jour donné si vous entrez
sur le terrain pour un moment ne pourra pas
sentir cette herbe
cette odeur de sable qu'il ressentait
enfant quand il est allé jouer pendant des heures
avec ses amis sur le terrain pour briser le
genoux ou d'user les écoles de
semelles de chaussures uniquement pour pur
amusant
et ce qui reste de la fleur
je dis plus
ici, ils viennent aux mains et aux mains
images
tous ensemble entre
bien